good afternoon we at the American Stock
Exchange together with Donaldson Lufkin
and generate Merrill Lynch and Smith
Barney are proud to be sharing this
great adventure with you I think I think
we are demonstrating that our nation's
can cooperate to their mutual advantage
every year before these sessions get
underway one of the first questions that
I'm asked by overseas visitors is what
is the thinking of the federal reserve
board this year I was able to respond
that we would soon hear the board's
viewpoint firsthand from its
vice-chairman manual Johnson when dr.
Johnson first became a board member in
February of 1986 some thought that his
strong economic views would rile the
waters during difficult decision making
but he quickly showed that he would
avoid personal feuds and focuses
considerable intellect on advancing
furthering the mission of the Federal
Reserve that's the same kind of
professionalism that dr. Johnson is
demonstrated in his earlier performance
at the Treasury Department there he won
the department's highest honor award
known as the Alexander Hamilton Award
while at the Treasury as assistant
secretary he had a major role in
formulating the United States economic
policy dr. Johnson holds a doctorate in
economics he's a university professor of
economics and he's written four books in
over 50 articles on political economy
and public policy certainly the time
could not be more appropriate nor the
man more appropriate than dr. Manuel
Johnson
thank you very much our ID it's my
pleasure to be here today I maybe might
I realize from your perspective the
timing is appropriate I'm not sure from
my viewpoint picked the perfect time to
be here today but but I but I think in a
way I I really have maybe this is the
most convenient time for me to address
this group at a time when there seems to
be some volatility in the stock markets
and some concern because I think it's
important to try and point out some of
the economic fundamentals that exist in
the free trading system in the US
economy in particular today and and try
and see if we can't focus on those
issues and avoid some of the current
uneasiness with animal spirits and the
markets and I think that's a good place
to start I think really in terms of
talking about the economy we should we
should briefly look at the situation in
some historical perspective before
talking about the implications of
current issues and I think the the first
thing that comes to mind when you look
at the performance of the US economy
over the last five years is that that
the economy indeed has expanded under
interrupted for five years about to
enter its six-year of economic expansion
and that this is now the longest
peacetime expansion in the post-war era
and I think you can go back good deal
further than that in addition to that
and I think the more the other very
interesting fact about current economic
issues is that that not only is this the
longest peacetime expansion but even in
spite of what's been happening recently
inflation rate and interest rates are as
low or lower today than they were when
this recovery began at the
nineteen eighty two most of you may find
that unusual but that's still still a
fact that interest rates and inflation
rates are generally is lower lower today
than when this expansion began and that
is also a very unusual event that's
really unprecedented in post-war
expansions now I don't want to sit here
and say though that that the that the
economic situation doesn't have its risk
I think it's important to point out some
of these fundamental strengths and I
think that this does point out that the
future course of the economy has great
potential that given these fundamental
facts that the inflationary pressures
seem to be modest and that interest
rates even though they have gone up
recently or still lower than when the
expansion began indicates that there is
still quite a bit of strength
fundamental strength to the economy and
that that the free trading system has
the opportunity to continue expanding
for some time without destabilizing
forces taking place now as I said this
situation is not without its risk of
course and I think that there are some
obvious issues that you're all well
aware of that have to be addressed and
ultimately dealt with if we're going to
continue to have an economic expansion
without financial instability and
inflationary problems and those obvious
issues are associated primarily with the
US federal budget deficit and our
deficit they in trade and the associated
surpluses in the industrial among the
industrial trading partners so indeed
there are these international imbalances
of large trade deficit in the United
States and large peoplee large trade
surpluses among its industrial trading
partners and a very large federal budget
deficit still to be addressed
but I should point out though that
progress is even being made there I
think we shouldn't lose sight of some of
the progress that's been made in this
particular area I think one of the
concerns of course about about such
large imbalances in the pre trading
system is though that with the u.s.
running a significant federal budget
deficit and requiring a substantial
amount of private savings for its
financing as well as trying to continue
to have an investment expansion at the
same time requires a continuation of net
capital inflows from abroad because our
domestic savings is not at a level to
satisfy both domestic investment and
government consumption and therefore
there is a need for capital in fort
imports from abroad and as long as
that's the case there has to be the
other side of the coin which is a
current account deficit and so as long
as we are reliant on foreign sources of
capital flows to sustain the domestic
economy as well as government
consumption there will be a persistent
trade deficit and a growing external
debt but as I mentioned a minute ago I
think that that's the major concern but
as I mentioned a minute ago I think that
we have to focus on some of the games
that have been made in this area and
realize that we have made a good deal of
progress and that we roughly have the
these imbalances moving in the right
direction and the economy is generally
on the right track let me point out that
that just during this last fiscal year
at the US federal budget deficit has
come down between 60 and 70 billion
dollars from its peak level of 221
billion dollars in 19th and fiscal 1986
this is a dramatic turnaround in the
federal budget deficit equal to about
1.5 to 1.6 percent of gross national
product which is an exceptional a change
in the direction of
a federal spending as a percentage GNP
and as an absolute amount and this has
taken place with no basic improvement in
the nominal current account deficit at
this point in other words we're still
receiving into the u.s. basically the
same net capital inflow as before and on
top of that we've had roughly a 60 to 70
billion dollar reduction in the federal
budget deficit in other words we've had
a 60 to 70 billion dollar reduction in
government demands own own private
saving both domestically and from abroad
so that there has been an increased
capacity for private domestic investment
through the sum of the relief in the
direction of the federal budget deficit
and I think that this needs to be
pointed out in addition to that the
Congress passed and the president signed
an additional amended version of the
gramm-rudman-hollings amendment and this
will require an additional twenty three
billion dollars in in either budget
reduction or spending reduction
specifically depending on how the budget
priorities get resolved in this Congress
but in fact they did the Congress and
the president did renew the sequester
ation process by making a constitutional
through allowing O&B to be the
sequestering agency and in fact now
there is a stronger discipline on the
domestic spending picture because if
budget priorities aren't sorted out by
sometime in November there will be a an
automatic sequestering across the board
or federal expenditures equally between
defense and non-defense spending on the
order of about 223 billion dollars for
fiscal 1988 this will continue to move
the federal budget deficit in a
direction I think that that shows
continued improvement should continue to
reduce the
deficit as a percentage GNP and in
absolute amounts and so I think it would
it's important to point out the progress
that had been made over the last two
fiscal years in trying to deal with this
particular problem now on the external
debt and the folk the trade deficit I
think it's important to point out that
progress has also been made as I
mentioned you cannot see a turn yet in
the current account overall current
account deficit although the last
month's numbers were slightly lower for
august then in July some people some
analysts were a little disappointed with
the degree of improvement and there's
been some nervousness and the financial
markets over this particular issue but I
should point out that that significant
progress in the federal trade deficit is
underway in real terms volume terms of
trade the US trade deficit has improved
by up to 30 billion dollars in real
terms since the third quarter of 1986
and in fact the improvement in real net
exports has contributed roughly
one-third of the real GNP growth rate
that we've enjoyed over the last three
quarters in the US economy so in fact
trade is turning in a positive direction
that is supporting real growth rather
than putting a drag on the performance
of the US economy and I think this is an
important event now in spite of that
improvement in the real volume of trade
we still haven't seen any major
improvement in the nominal current
account deficit and I think one of the
reasons for this is that it takes awhile
for contracts to be renegotiated at the
changed prices so that in fact you get
larger volumes under old contract prices
which temporarily intensifies the
nominal trade account before it gets
better of course this is known as the
j-curve effect where first you see an
improvement in real terms in the volume
of trade before you see an improvement
in the actual amount that you have to
finance which is the
aminul current account but of course we
have seen the current account peek out
over recent months and not increase in
size in addition to that I think if you
were to subtract that the data show that
if you were subtract out all imports
that you would find that the nominal
current account has actually been
improving to in the areas of a non oil
trade in fact the bilateral trade
balance has been showing some
improvement between the two major circle
surplus countries between Germany and
Japan so part of the problem is that the
recent rise in oil prices back from the
ten to the twenty dollar range has
masked what would have been an
improvement by now in the nominal
current account deficit and I think this
shouldn't go unrecognized because of
this I think temporary effect of the oil
price on own oil import values you
haven't seen this improvement but in
fact the Federal Reserve is forecasting
a fairly significant improvement
phenomenal current account for 1988 and
a continued improvement in real terms on
the order of what we've already seen so
I think that even in terms of the trade
imbalance situation we are moving
generally in the right directions these
imbalances are coming down both in the
domestic budget and in the external debt
situation and so the stage i think is
being set for a healthy continued
expansion without without inflationary
instability however there are still
other questions and i think because of
these imbalances about the future course
of economic policy in the US and maybe
this is one of the sources of financial
uncertainty that permeates the market
today and has led to some of the the
Troublesome volatility that we've seen i
think a significant question in the
financial markets is actually how policy
is going to deal with these imbalances
in the future and what direction
economic policy will in fact take and
will the direction of policy in
terms of fiscal and regulatory policy
put the Federal Reserve in a tight box
that makes our decisions more difficult
and and has to make tough decisions
about the inflationary instability that
would otherwise not have to make and I
think that's some of the concern that
maybe in the financial markets today and
so it matters how we continue to try and
resolve these imbalances and I think
that one the things that we don't need
to see in the future our quick fix
solutions to the trade imbalance for
instance are for that matter in the
federal budget deficit the last thing we
need is in today's environment is is a
quick fix approach to the federal trade
deficit by say trying to already
artificially depress the dollar severely
below current levels this would simply I
think exacerbate the financial market
conditions and lead to further potential
for financial problems and in fact I
think that we already have a
depreciation in the dollar that is
underlying the improvement we're seeing
in the trade deficit at this point the
dollar has declined from its peak levels
in early nineteen eighty-five by about
forty to fifty percent against the major
industrial countries currencies the
Federal Reserve we're not hearing any
industry representatives over the 12
districts of the Federal Reserve that
are saying today that they can't compete
at roughly this level of exchange rates
in fact we're seeing strong pick up
strong improvement in orders for export
and for import substitution type
products so in fact we are getting the
recovery and trade that we've been
looking for and you can see it in
looking at the sectors associated with
trade sensitive areas so the exchange
rate i think has already made an
adjustment that brings us industry
roughly two competitive levels this is
one reason why I think it's kind of
interesting that there's been so much
stock market volatility because i think
the adjustment that we've seen to this
date would indicate that the earnings in
these categories and trade sensitive
sectors is going to be quite strong over
the months to come and so economic
performance i think should be quite
strong in the trade sensitive sectors of
the economy but i think as i mentioned
what we need from what we don't need at
this point after we've had a forty to
fifty percent adjustment in the exchange
rate against the other major industrial
countries currencies is to is to try and
depress the dollar dramatically from
this level on i think that what we have
begun to see in the recent past is that
the dollar in many cases the dollar is
easing from these levels in many cases
has been symptomatic of inflationary
expectations and because of this of
course the Federal Reserve has sought to
to try and deal with these rising
inflationary expectations by tightening
policy twice since the spring once in
the April May period once in September
with an increase in the disc a half
point the discount rate but since that
time we have not seen the type of
inflationary expectation increases that
we have been observing up until the time
when we increase the discount rate in
September so I think though that we are
we have to be observant that that
further depreciation in the exchange
rate if it appears symptomatic of and
rising inflationary expectations could
be a problem and they're trying to
artificially depress it to deal with our
trade imbalances would be I think I
think counterproductive but it's also
true that there are some qualifications
that need to be made about the exchange
rate first there are times when the
exchange rate is symptomatic of
inflationary expectations and there may
be other times
when it's not a good example of a period
when the exchange the Cline in the
dollar was not the symptomatic of
inflationary pressures was during most
of 1986 during 1986 we saw significant
depreciation of the dollar but that
depreciation of the dollar was also
consistent with continual rally in the
bond markets strength in the stock
markets and in fact a decline in
long-term interest rates during that
entire period so that depreciating
dollar during 1986 was not a signal of
inflationary expectations indeed it was
a period when the federal budget deficit
was coming down sharply and all prices
were also falling so that the
fundamentals in terms of the improvement
in the inflation outlook overwhelmed any
adjustment in the exchange rate so I
don't think it's an exchange rate in
both the bond markets and movements in
broader commodity prices and
inflationary and the broader
inflationary indexes to see whether it's
also consistent movements and exchange
rates are also consistent with
inflationary expectations and I think
that that what we had seen during our
tight I period periods when we had
tightened previously was a consistent
picture in that direction that
inflationary expectations were building
not only through signified by some
weakness in the dollar exchange rate but
in sharp movements in upward movements
and broad indexes of commodities and in
some of the broader inflation indexes as
well as in a sharp steepening in the in
the interest rate yield curve since our
moves to moderate inflationary
expectations with our tightening
policies we have seen these expectation
allah forces settle down some we have
seen the yield curve up until just the
last few days start to flatten out most
recently I think we've seen
Treasury bill rates fall relative to the
long end of the market mainly due to
some flight to quality recently and this
is I think somewhat artificially
depressed the short end of the Treasury
bill market but in fact up until
recently we have seen a flattening in
the Treasury yield curve we have seen
the modification of commodity prices and
the broader inflation indexes and
chairman Greenspan has recently said
that looking at the fundamentals on the
inflation side that that the data don't
actually appear representative of any
further upward movements in inflationary
pressures and so since so we have seen
the kind of expectation of forces
develop I think that we've been
satisfied with since our last discount
rate move and we've maintained a steady
monetary policy but once again one of
the other issues I think that we have to
try and avoid as well as trying to to
pursue quick fix solutions through
dramatic reductions in the exchange rate
when in fact we're already competitive
at this level of exchange rates and
further sharp declines would simply be
troubling to the financial markets I
think in and and raise concerns about
inflationary expectations we also have
to worry about quick fix solutions
through the protectionist trade route
and I think we get to the same basic
result in that direction if we tried to
depress imports artificially into the US
market by serious trade protection
legislation that would cut off the flow
of imports in the US economy you would
have a tremendous restriction in the
flow of foreign capital into the u.s. to
support the financing of imports and you
would see sharp drops in the dollar and
financial instability in the same way
that you would if you tried to depress
the dollar artificially from the
beginning and so these are approaches
that we have to avoid we have to avoid
protectionist trade legislation we have
to avoid attempts to artificially to
press the dollar if we're going to
to make the transition to a continued
expansion without inflationary pressures
and financial instability and I think
that that's the direction we have to
seek and that's the direction that
putting put some monetary policy at ease
and avoid some of the tough decisions
that the Federal Reserve would have to
make otherwise I want to point out also
on the exchange rate in conclusion that
that there's one other source I think of
potential exchange rate weakness that
wouldn't necessarily imply inflationary
expectations I've already mentioned the
fact that all price movements and other
fundamentals that allow some dollar
depreciation without a concern of
inflationary expectations feeding into
the bond market there's also the
potential for foreign central banks to
over tighten monetary policy in a way
that would raise interest rates abroad
and attract capital but not have the
same significance for domestic inflation
in the US economy that might otherwise
take place if monetary policy were too
easy in the United States so I think you
have to be careful to determine what's
what's the cause of dollar depreciation
is it because of rising inflationary
expectations in the domestic economy or
is it because overly tight central bank
policies abroad or is it because of
sharply declining oil prices are some of
the fundamental movement it's very
important what the source of those
exchange rate developments is in terms
of its implications for inflationary
expectations so on a final note I think
I'm I've tried to point out the
strengths and the fundamentals in the
economy and what needs to be done to
further improve those fundamentals by
dealing with the two major risk factors
in the economy today the large federal
budget deficit in the trade imbalance
that we face but there's a way to
proceed in a way not to proceed and I
think that we have a great opportunity
to continue a stable expansion without
inflationary pressures if we move in the
direction that we've moved in the recent
past by continuing to work down the
federal budget deficit by trying to
improve our structural and adjust
improve the structural factors in the
economy like productivity improvements
rather than trying to artificially
depress the exchange rate to solve our
problems from this level we've gotten a
reasonable exchange rate adjustment
that's allowing our industries to
compete without stimulating inflationary
pressures but from this point on I think
we have to be careful about where we go
with exchange rate policy and it's very
important how we resolve our trade
imbalances from here on there are no
quick fix solutions to this we have to
take this take on these issues in a
systematic way and in a stable way and I
think if we move in that direction
monetary policy will be able to support
the expansion without inflationary
without having to deal with inflationary
pressures thank you very much
I promise to take some questions at this
point I should start off by saying
before I take any questions that that I
want to avoid talking about any
directions directly associated with
current monetary policy I know that may
preclude a lot of my questions but I
don't think this is appropriate time to
be talking about specific monetary
policy but any other questions I'll be
happy to entertain yes sir
I think around the world with everybody
is making business and dollars so at the
end and aware and nozzles and in dollars
and if you had not a deficit the trade
deficit the work would have a shortage
of dollars and you could have the corner
in the market so don't you think that's
been set up in the trade deficit as a
problem solving for some free world it
is in fact a good thing for us to have
you in deficit and supplying to work
with lawless well one of the I think one
of the points that I was trying to make
about not seeking quick fix solutions to
the trade deficit problem was that in
fact the United States is a world
reserve currency the US dollar is a
world reserve currency the United States
has always been a key currency country
and much of international trade is
conducted in dollar denominated terms
and so because of this key currency
status of the United States there is an
exceptional demand for dollars that
wouldn't otherwise be the case and
therefore because much of international
contra dollar-denominated and there is a
strong demand for dollars we're going to
see net capital inflows into the United
States at least for a reasonable future
and so because of this we don't want to
disrupt that flow of transactions by
trying to solve our trade deficit
problems overnight we can as i mentioned
trying to eliminate the trade deficit in
a very short time risk a substantial
outflow of foreign capital and a
disruption of trade that is highly
nominated in dollar days and would make
it very difficult for the financial
markets and so i think the point is that
we have to we have to use our common
sense about dealing with this problem I
don't think that we want to continue to
persistently run a trade deficit on an
indefinite basis but I think that over
the intermediate-term what we need to
worry about
is getting the trade deficit down to a
level that makes it internationally
financeable rather than trying to simply
erase it overnight because we do depend
substantially own foreign capital flows
into the domestic market for the reasons
that I've already mentioned and trying
to disrupt that flow of capital I think
would be very unfortunate so what we
need to do is gradually work down the
trade deficit we've already had an
adjustment in the exchange rate I think
it's starting us on that course in a
stable fashion but further sharp
reductions in the exchange rate I think
would be unfortunate in that direction
and so now I think we have to see how
much adjustment takes place at this is
level of exchange rates and avoid quick
fix solutions because the capital flow
disruptions could be important
the question was he assumes the spirit
of the g7 accord is still in place and
what changes what I like to see to that
Accord I guess for future in terms of
current developments is that it okay
first of all I think that's right the
spirit of the g7 accord still is in
place and in fact as I speak the
exchange rate has been has maintained
the much of its stability there has been
some depreciation the dollar against the
deutsche mark but against the yen and
most of the other industrial country
currencies the dollar has been quite
stable in fact most people don't realize
that there's really been no net dollar
depreciation against the 10 major
industrial country currencies in 1987 in
fact the lube Accord has worked very
well in terms of stabilizing exchange
rates and I think that that spirit still
remains but i think that there's there
is some discussion about who does what
within that accord and and whose turn it
is to to make to to make a move in terms
of stabilizing exchange rates in order
to avoid any any sharp exchange rate
moves and i think there have been some
recent discussions of course between the
u.s. i guess and and West Germany about
their need for tighter policies and
higher interest rates in a period when
their economy doesn't show strong signs
of growth and and no rise in inflation
and is it necessary to narrow interest
differentials in an environment like
that and I think that this gets back to
one of the points that I made earlier is
that that the inflationary significance
of the exchange rate depends on whether
the exchange rate an exchange rate
weakness is symptomatic of
easier monetary policy in the US which
may be supporting rise and inflationary
expectations versus too tight a monetary
policy may be abroad it might be
strengthening the value of some foreign
country's currency relatives the US
dollar those have totally different
implications in terms of their
inflationary potential and I think if
the parties can sort out these
differences that the the spirit of lube
record will remain of course is
desirable I think to have it remain and
maintain rough stability and exchange
rates barring any external shocks to the
system but once again it's important to
have an understanding of who do does wyd
in that system if we're going to
maintain stability and exchange rates
caution against the effective
protectionists types of developments
defect it'll happen to our trading
partners and so forth and advocate
continued budgetary restraint in
reducing the budget deficit yet pentagon
just released a report the last party
which said that it's a grand blood and
some question goes into fact it'll cut
the defense budget by 35 and a half
billion dollars and that could have just
as severe and effect with regard to our
relations to our allies not only
militarily but also economically as
problems with regard to trade correctly
how do you respond to them well I
responded that to start with by simply
saying that I'm not a defense expert and
as someone focused mainly on monetary
policy and the overall economic policies
as well I can't really comment on the
significance of any particular budget
reduction in the defense area I think
that's for some other person to try and
address but I think it's important to
point out though that that the reduction
in the budget deficit of the 23 billion
billion that I mentioned is significant
and important I don't know I'm no expert
on the issues between budget priorities
whether it comes out of domestic or
defense but I simply can't say that
reducing the rate of growth of federal
spending by 23 billion dollars annually
can't be all bad that's got to be a good
thing
yes I think there was a report in the in
the French newspapers that I had made a
comment about the Federal Reserve
targeting the price of gold but my only
reference was that that the price of
gold like commodity prices and bond
yields and the exchange rate had all
been roughly stable since our last
discount rate move and that that gold
the gold price is one thing we look at
at at the feds as well as commodity
prices exchange rates and and bond
yields among many other things and that
I was pointing out the rough stability
in its price but it has notes that
comment had no significance in terms of
targeting the gold price of course we're
not we're only looking at prices of
commodities as leading indicators of
price expectations among many other
variables do you agree with make on the
German monetary policy but you don't
agree on this solution that they could
boast for it but what other solution do
you see because it seems that the g7 is
not working well in the expect of
central bank's advising each other what
they was all going to do well I think
the question was that the g7 agreement
doesn't appear to be working that well
in the basis of who does what and
whether i supported secretary Baker's
recent recommendations about what maybe
revaluing currencies to some extent
first first of all I think I think I'd
point out that i don't think the g7 has
worked at badly as a matter of fact I
think rough stability and exchange rates
during 1987 has not been a bad record at
all i think it has worked very well but
i think i think the point is that
recently there have been
make some disagreements over the
direction of relative domestic policies
in trying to stabilize exchange rates
and I think that what's going on is a
normal process of trying to coordinate
policy and and reach an understanding
but as I said this still has not
produced changes in exchange rates that
are outside the broad ranges of the g7
agreement Markus listen to the Fed at
the moment the markets are trying their
fed tradition the question was was as
the mark is the Fed listening to the
market the market seemed to be trying to
speak and are we paying attention I
think that was sort of the question well
of course we're paying attention as a
matter of fact I think the market
signals are very important for monetary
policy but as I pointed out I have not
seen anything inconsistent in what's
going on the financial markets with
stability and inflationary expectations
I think there was a period in the spring
and early summer when we were seeing
some signs of rising inflationary forces
and of course this is justified the
moves that we made up until that time
since then I think we've seen some of
the surveys of inflationary expectations
actually come down i think mr. Hoey
survey at drexel burnham of Wall Street
executives on inflationary expectations
as as dropped recently from previous
levels we have not seen sharp increases
in commodity prices nor in the broader
inflationary indexes labor costs unit
labor costs are still well under control
and shows no signs of sharply
intensifying in terms of upward pressure
the fundamentals look very well we have
seen recent pressures and the broader
indexes of inflation from the recent
rise in all prices are
clear from the 10 to 20 billion dollar
range and there's still some feeding
through going on of the previous
adjustment down the dollar exchange rate
but as I mentioned we've had rough
stability in exchange rates during this
year and so we don't expect to see
further feeding through after this one
wears off of rising price pressures due
to exchange rate movements as I said
we've had 10 months now of roughly
stable exchange rates and this will I
think I think begin to show through in
declining inflationary expectations as
well as the fact that all prices have
stopped their rise and shows some signs
of coming down some of course there are
always tensions in the Mideast and we're
obviously those today it may cause that
to fluctuate but we are watching the
markets I think that in fact there
appears to be a large risk premium in
the markets these days over uncertainty
about some of these questions I've
raised today but I don't think it's
inflationary expectations at least the
evidence is not consistent with what
we'd seen earlier on inflationary
pressure and so I think you have to look
elsewhere for your evidence I think mr.
Levin has pointed out that my time is up
and so thank you very much